can everyone hear me okay great all
right well thanks everyone for coming to
our sustainability Meetup
today we're gonna be talking about some
of the machine learning research
projects that we've been working on the
past couple months specifically catered
towards energy efficiency and customer
care real quick I'm gonna introduce my
data science team there's been Packer
Zero and Mark and they're gonna be
coming up here and presenting some of
these with me okay so first I'll just go
over the quick agenda we're gonna be
going over the background about Opower
along with what the data science team
does then we're gonna talk about some of
the load curve archetypes that we've
been researching then I'll talk about
the small medium business insights that
we have and then we'll finish it off
with electric vehicle detection so I
want to start with a small energy
savings experiment that was done a few
years ago with the aim to figure out
what's the most effective way to get
people to save energy so they put these
placards on people's front doors the
first one said save energy and you'll
save more money the next one said save
energy and you'll save the planet and
the third one said save energy and
you'll be a good citizen so which one of
these three do you think was the most
effective at getting people to save
energy very good guess but it's a trick
question none of these actually had any
impact on energy consumption at all it
turns out that the only one that did was
a fourth placard that said your
neighbors are saving more energy than
you are and even if that wasn't true
people still were so competitive that
they actually saved money when they were
given this placard so that's kind of
where the idea for power came in and we
decided to make a home energy report
with the idea that if we were able to
compare people's energy to their
neighbors and actually inform them about
their energy usage then they'd have the
highest chance of actually saving energy
so here we have a mock-up of our home
energy report and you can see the bar
chart is comparing your energy usage to
your neighbors and your most efficient
neighbors the neighbors here are going
to be people approximately
homes of a similar size within a similar
or within a short radius of your house
and then along with this we also provide
tips on how you can save energy and more
information about that so this is our
first big project our product the Home
Energy Report next is our behavioral
demand response so traditional behavior
demand response required customers to
actually sign up for these devices that
would be installed in their homes for
say a twenty five dollar rebate and then
on the peak days like the hottest day of
the year when everyone's using the most
energy and you would go to turn your air
conditioning up it would block you so
that you wouldn't be using as much
energy on these peak consumption days
however because this requires you
signing up to actually get this
installed in your house there was very
very low adaptability so Opower went for
a softer program called the behavioral
dishonest behavioral demand response
program where you actually will get a
text message or an email asking you hey
tomorrow is going to be a peak day
please limit your usage between the
hours of 2:00 and 7:00 and some of these
programs will have monetary value so
they will give you a rebate if you don't
use as much and the adaptability is very
high all we need is your email or your
tech or your cell phone number and we'll
be able to send you these communications
and these are actually very very
effective without monetary gains I want
to say it was between 3 and 5 percent
energy reduction and then with the
monetary incentive it was a 10 percent
reduction in peak energy usage on these
peak days and that's really important
because for the peak days if you run out
of capacity as a utility company you
have to start up these peaker plants and
those often use fossil fuels and we know
those are all bad so that is our second
big product how is it deployed in the
wild well we send a communication the
day before or before the peak day saying
please don't use energy between these
times and then we also give you your
neighbor comparison
for the last peak day so that you can
see that you could be doing a lot better
trying to give you that competitive
advantage of edge then on the peak day
we're hoping that you turn up your
thermostat a little bit so you turn down
your air conditioning you don't use as
much and then after the peak day we'll
send you a follow-up communication
saying great job look at you
you were one of your efficient neighbors
way to go so that's a little bit about
old powers too
big products now data science at O power
here's some of our data science members
it's a nice big team we work on a
variety of different projects some of
which we're going to be presenting today
and with the goal to deliver them to
improve the experience either for the
utility customer or the utility client
or their customers a little bit of the
workflow we start in the research stage
with an idea we take some data and we
figure out okay is there any signal with
in this data with these models we try a
bunch of different models and if there
is signal then we will and if we
actually can have decent accuracy then
we will move it to an initial rollout
and a small population either a single
client or a small pilot program if that
goes well then we will release it for
general availability and that includes
all of the production ization within
that and then after that we will go back
to the research and we will consider
model improvements and we'll do more
accuracy testing and then potentially go
through the whole thing again for a v2
so today we're going to be talking about
some of the projects that we have in our
research stage
we have two microphones and well in the
clicker we good
all right so I'm gonna talk about
actually before I begin one thing John
neglected to mention is that today is
the 60 year anniversary of Justine
graduating high school and the only
reason I say that is because she didn't
want me to say that okay so I'm gonna
talk about this is actually something in
that we do in production using ami data
smart meter data to segment customers
understand their behaviors better so I'm
gonna start with my own data I live in
Redwood City and this is a monthly view
of what my electric energy usage looks
like this is for each month the average
usage in my home and you can see that I
use more energy in the winter and
actually when I first saw this I was a
little surprised because you would think
in the summer use more electricity but
actually I don't have since it's Redwood
City I don't really have
air-conditioning don't really need
air-conditioning and in the winter
that's when we blast up the heat we also
have some not great insulation so we use
a little too much of the heat in the
summer even though it's even though it's
gas heat we're still using just more
energy in the system in general anyway
so this is what my what my profile looks
like this doesn't tell you that much
about me or really about my behaviors
but if we dig into these I have since I
have a mi data we can look at that and
see what that looks like so what I'm
showing here is across the lifetime of
my home or when I was there for each
hour of the day what is the average
energy usage electric energy usage so
each hour this is just the average my
average usage and so what you can see
you can see a few things here first is
that we probably wake up on in general
around 7:00 so there's a little little
spike in the morning someone is usually
home during the day so my daughter and
our Nana usually in and out of the house
during the day and then we come home in
the evening we have dinner we watch who
or whatever and then we go to sleep okay
so this gives you some sort of sense of
what my life is like a little weird but
it's fine
it would be great if we can do this for
all utility customers to try and gain
some insight into what their behaviors
are and then I'll we'll talk about what
we can do with that
but I want to back up and just show you
what data raw data looks like I don't
know if everyone's seen this but this is
pretty typical of a single households
energy usage electric usage for a name
from an ami meter for a single day so
one day this is one random customer that
I chose this is real data so you know
maybe there's some pattern here maybe
not it looks a little noisy if you take
this this customer and take the same
plot over five consecutive days this is
what it looks like so each line here is
a single day of usage and this is five
consecutive days again pretty noisy
maybe there's some pattern here they
seem to use a little bit more in the
evening but you know there's a lot of
fluctuation and then this is overall
time so this is this customers data
overall time very noisy really not much
that you can discern here however if we
take the average overall time then maybe
you can get some sense of the pattern
you do lose some information but you can
see for example that just like me they
seem to wake up around 7:00 they get a
little spike in the morning where
they're having their coffee and then
they actually kind of similar to me you
know come home in the evening maybe
they're around during the day and then
they have and they they go down in the
evening after they go to sleep okay so
let's take this average curve load curve
and plot it for all customers that we
have so this is just a sampling of a
thousand customers and we call this we
call this chart the hairball because it
looks like a hairball it's very again
hard to discern any pattern here and
drive any meaning from it so what we did
is we took all this data for all the
customers and we applied a clustering
algorithm to it so we're gonna just
throw this data into the clustering
algorithm and retrieve from it some
number of clusters salient clusters of
people that are similar to each other
and different from others and so here's
what happened when we did that we get
out these five different clusters and
let me add some the color to it so you
can see it more clearly so these are
these five different clusters that
emerge from this and I wanna emphasize
that this is not something that we went
searching for five in particular with
these particular shapes and in fact let
me show you them separately so you can
see what each one looks like separately
we didn't say let's look for something
with like two humps
which is probably someone who leaves
home for work during the day or
something up in the upper right corner
where someone is using a lot in the
evening this is all naturally emerging
from the data and five in particular is
we we ran this for different numbers of
clusters and this is the one five was
like the right balance between
explaining the data and simplicity we
also gave them kind of funny names
steady eddies Twin Peaks etc we so now
we have these and each customer now is
assigned to one of these clusters so
there are some people who are Twin Peaks
there's some people who are daytimers
etc and we took those assignments and we
correlated them with demographic data
that we have so we saw for example that
daytimers is you might expect tend to
skew a little older and have fewer
children in the house night owls tend to
be younger apartment condo dwellers you
would assume that day timers tend to be
or may be more likely to be retirees so
this gives you some sense of who they
are however one thing that is really
trouble is a taupe hour for basically
the entirety of our existence is that we
run all these energy efficiency programs
we want to figure out who and they work
very well in general every wave that
we've ever done we've measured
rigorously with randomized control
trials and the savings are always
between about 1.5 and 3% overall savings
but we wanted to figure out who are the
people who are most likely to save
because that way we can target those
people and get higher overall savings
and we've never found anything we've
looked at all sorts of different
demographic categories age income even
political leanings and for any given
territory utility sometimes there will
be some sort of correlation but it never
holds across the the full population or
across other utilities so there's really
been nothing that we found that predicts
higher energy savings other than higher
energy usage so that's that's basically
it if you use more you're more likely to
save it's pretty straightforward and
that's how we target our programs and
we've been unable to find any other
subset of the population to target until
we had these load curve archetypes so
despite the fact that demographics alone
does not predict a EE savings and the
fact that our local
archetypes are correlated to these
demographics demographic categories in
general the low curve archetypes
themselves alone are actually very
predictive and there's a strong
correlation so on the energy efficiency
side our for our home energy reports you
see that the daytimers are have a much
higher savings rate and this is this
pretty significant difference in the
savings rate overall on the demand
response side the steady Eddie's really
stand out as those who really save the
least and I think this is what's
important to see here is that so if you
look at the steady Eddie's what I didn't
mention is that the y-axis is percentage
use of your overall usage so this is not
absolute usage this is percentage of
your overall usage which means that if
you can be you can use a ton of energy
or a little energy it's just about the
shape and that's what puts you into this
category so you can have very high and
very low users that are both steady
Eddie's and the difference between these
categories is what the shape is and in
the case of demand response what that
means is do you have the ability to
change your electric usage throughout
the day or are you willing to or do you
have the ability to and steady Eddie's
tend to be people who don't they don't
have that ability and that is why they
are saving at a lower rate it's being
may have a huge amount of afternoon
usage during that peak period but they
just don't have either they're never
home or they're always wrong whatever it
is they're not they're not changing
their behavior whereas the evening
papers are really the ones who are able
to change their behavior the most and
save the most so real quick what let's
see I can do this in two ways one is to
guess which is the most let's do
guessing all right what does everyone
think the most common archetype is
across the population that we've looked
at twin peak any other guesses
Eddie's evening peakers correct on the
third try evening peekers are the most
this by the way does vary by utility and
you know geography but across the
population we've looked at the the Twin
Peaks are actually surprised so that was
my first guess initially when we looked
at this but those are actually less
common evening pickers are more common
so how do we actually use this so this
is all in production right now it is
which means that it's run automatically
in any of our products and we do more
than just the Home Energy reports are
able to have access to this property for
each household we have so we can if we
want to have a campaign that's sending
out certain communications if it's a
refrigerator rebate program that a
utility is marketing they have the
ability through our bi tool to target
just people in that particular
households with a particular archetype
it's one of the many ways that we
segment the population and this is now
included so you can now our partners can
now target by these low shave archetypes
and then as I mentioned we're for demand
response in particular this has a very
strong effect and so we have we have now
have the ability to target the demand
response programs to the people who are
going to save the most so now I want to
turn it over to Xero who has done a
recent project extending this we
basically got asked by one of our
partners to do a couple things one is to
look to show them what their archetypes
look like in particular every utility
thinks they're very special and of
course they're all very special and they
want to see what their archetypes look
like and they also wanted to see
different seasonal effects and they're
they're trying to craft their own time
abuse rates and so they wanted to be
informed by this so I'll turn it over to
Xero to talk about that
Mike so my name is zero and I'm pretty
new to machine learning and data science
I was nice of adjusting to include me
into the data science team I mean my
work is data science work but I'm
actually a implementation engineer
working at Opower
but I'm really interested in the subject
and I'm also very new to the energy
industry but I'm very excited to share
the progress of my work with you guys
tonight
and I apologize if you know my slides
does not look so fancy as Ben's slides
which goes for you know sales
presentation but you know it's real work
and my real hard time so thanks all
right here we go so here yeah so my
project is to the load curve archetypes
for a specific utility partner of ours
and here to start with I plotted three
individual customers with their average
hourly ami data throughout the day and I
said as been mentioned before we
actually translated the actual ami read
into the percentage throughout the daily
percentage use this way we see the usage
shift throughout as the day goes by very
clearly as you guys can see they are
very different individuals with the
different patterns as the first guy is
probably a average nine-to-fiver as you
can see the peaks around the morning
oops a more amount the morning time and
the night time and during the day is
relatively lower and the second person
is actually pretty steady as you can see
that the difference between the
percentage is only one and the third guy
for some reason they have some
heavy-duty energy used in the morning so
as we can see only the three people
right here is already really different
so how about more
so here we got the hairball again that
been mentioned before just with more
colors because I thought it was prettier
so but you know like here we can kind of
see the patterns kind of like during the
morning time we see kind of a peak and
then again the night time the evening
time we see a like a lower peak and
right here we you kind of see a low
curve but in general this is still
pretty noisy so how do we understand
this better we turn to machine learning
and in this specific situation we use
clustering and particularly for me I
used the k-means algorithm from a
psychic learner and you know for case
value we actually tested from 2 to 20
and finally we found that 1 K is equal
to 5 it brings us the groups with the
most distinctive characters so here's
what we found we got this very nice 5
curves and you can kind of see oops
sorry here we actually got the steady
Eddy that been mentioned earlier as the
purple curve you can see it's pretty
steady throughout the day and also we
got this red curve over here which is
kind of have the twin peak and
especially at night like it's it's a lot
higher so this is the night owl so we do
see some similarity like with Ben's
general curves but what's interesting is
this light blue curve we see right here
this does not look similar with any of
Ben's curves which the energy usage is
actually concentrated between you know
nighttime and morning time and
throughout the day is pretty low so this
might worth more investigation and
research later on and also we can kind
of see on the right I put a percentage
of the customer that falls into
different
groups here interestingly you know for
the steady Eddie the group is the
biggest because I remember some some of
you guys guessed earlier like which one
is the most common but apparently for
this specific utility a partner the
steady Eddie is the most common type
which might have something to do with
the region they are at maybe there are
just more retired people but I'm not
gonna say that utility name obviously
but you guys can have a guess but you
know despite the difference between you
know my project with Ben's general
research we can still use all this five
different types to generate more insight
so we can get better population
segmentation has been showed you guys
earlier so that using that we can target
or we can use better target for our
energy efficiency programs and also as
Ben mentioned that we can have better
energy efficiency savings forecast more
accurate so now how about when we
introduce seasons into the picture you
know the data I was using I'm using for
this project is from a region I'm giving
a lot of details but just without the
name the the region that you know this
between the change between winter and
summer is pretty drastic that's why we
decided to introduce season into the
cluster generating and this is what we
found here we can see between the winter
curves and the summer curves there is
they're pretty different and the most
obvious difference between these two is
this peak I kind of disappeared over
here but it makes sense like in the
summer the temperature probably rise a
lot and you know between the nighttime
and in the morning like people just
don't need to turn on the heat that much
as they do in the winter
so you know like using when we in
tradition in this research we can
actually adjust our program targeting
strategy so we can get better result so
so far I've pretty much covered all the
progress I've made in my project and the
next step I'm gonna take is to see if
for the same customers if winter and
summer energy consumption behaviors can
correlate for example if in the winter
certain people fall into this category
which there is a peak between the night
and morning time when the summer comes
will they fall into this group or this
group or both because you know like when
the temperature rise they're not going
to use as much energy so you will see as
my project goes on so the conclusion is
that clustering customers based on the
ami data brings more brings in more ways
for us to identify behavioral groups so
that we can you know a target the
utility customers better with our energy
efficiency programs and be to provide
more accurate energy efficiency savings
forecast and last you know facts like
seasons might be worth looking into
so that's it for me today thank you guys
I'll see if I can answer if I can't I
just look at him
yes that's actually another part of my
later research are you talking about in
general when we do these demand response
programs using the general occurs the
target the programs yeah
so we're that's we show that the past
correlation we're now doing the
targeting and then we'll measure the
effects and that's not in yet yeah it's
roughly I mean it's almost not really
not too much extra complication beyond
as we said we take the percentage and
then we do Euclidean distance there's a
few other versions of what we have the
simple things tend to work about the
same as yeah yes I don't so what I do
remember is that we have all this
written down somewhere and the the ones
that I believe stand out are that the
day oh man now I forget all right I
think it's either day timers or the
night owls Nemo but but there's actually
only two I think that stand out as
either higher or lower and other than
that there's kind of a mix and even when
the ones that do stand out there's a big
mix so I think it might have been the
night owls who use more energy but it's
not consistent across the population
full population there's definitely yeah
right right and the reason and so when I
mentioned that the savings are higher or
lower for each category that's when
adjusting for total usage so it's not
just capturing the fact that higher
users save more it's even even adjusting
for that yeah
we don't so first of all our way up our
works in generals we partner with
utilities and they have so we run some
of our own programs that they buy from
us and then they also use a lot of our
software or in this case the
segmentation to run their own campaigns
and programs so what we've done is we've
made this available I think the only
thing that we've done internally is I've
investigated as targeting our demand
response program so far and there may be
other stuff that we do but we've given
our utility partners the ability to use
these low shape clusters as well as
other demographic or other pieces of
information
to segment the population and target
their communications and campaigns
appropriately so there are so I there is
a New Zealand utility that has recently
started using them and actually I should
forget the program that they were using
to target but we gave them the control
to target their marketing to whichever
archetypes that they found were most
likely to yield results I think you had
a question too
yeah so this is only electricity and the
reason is that we have because we're
looking at the hourly view we have to
use am i smart meters and there
basically is I think in the world know
where that has smart meters less than a
day except for like two places maybe
that have hourly or sub hourly smart
meters for gas so this is all electric
smart meter we could easily do the same
thing it doesn't matter what the input
is so we can easily easily do the same
thing for gas but since you know
basically everyone who has smart meters
has electric that's that's what we do it
for
so for this analysis where we just use
the raw data the raw energy usage data
as input to this clustering analysis but
as I mentioned earlier we have we have
that other information at least
sometimes so for depending on the
territory we get third party information
that we put into our tools that we have
access to and that our utility partners
have access to and so they can use that
to segment and they do use that like age
of homes sometimes they use to target
you know retrofit or whatever programs
and they use all those properties of
households if they're available this is
a huge issue that the questions about
data yeah sorry the question was about
data ownership in general Oh power gets
data from utilities I'm mode what do we
do with it do we have to share your SMS
security and do we have to give it back
and stuff like that so we have this is a
again a huge issue at AU power because
it's kind of central to everything we do
what we're showing is the data science
part but really everything that ou power
does is centered around utility data
energy usage data that comes from
customers through the utility partners
and there are huge privacy issues and
legal issues and so every contract that
we sign we have you know we have a huge
legal team and a huge security team that
we make sure we're compliant with and we
have security on our site it is on our
sides we are able to bring it into our
data warehouse and then when if we lose
a contract or if the contract ends we
have a deletion policy where we'll
delete it and you know we go through
that process with so many utilities now
that is kind of standard and they have
trusted us and yeah
yeah
so the question is do different
incentives or different messaging as we
saw at the beginning different messaging
will affect people in different ways
have we looked at the breakdown by
archetype the answer that is we strongly
believe that there is something there
and this is relatively new and we have a
very strong UX and behavioural research
science research team that we kind of
want to work with to figure out is there
gonna be different messaging and I think
it has to be yes the people who are home
during the day should be message to
differently to accept to you know
participate in different programs
differently than people who are not home
during the day or you know have
different patterns of usage but that's
still sort of in in research yeah the
next time I want to let's get to the
other talk so let's defer more questions
till the end and we'll turn it over to
Justine
my slides okay cool so I'm going to be
talking about some of our small medium
business insights that we use to
classify business types so we have two
big products with small medium
businesses like I mentioned at the
beginning of the talk one of our first
products at Opower were the Home Energy
reports well for businesses we're doing
the business energy report and here we
have a lot of the similar modules as our
original home energy report and we are
comparing these companies to competitors
so here we've got OSHA tie it's around
the corner it's an Asian restaurant Thai
food and we want to compare it to other
Asian restaurants with similar hours in
the similar local similar location
because that is the best comparison so
we need to know from the restaurant name
what kind of business from the business
name what kind of business segment is it
so that we can actually compare it to
restaurants we don't want to be
comparing OSHA Thai to a Walgreens
basically so that's one product and then
the second is a lot of tips targeted
tips based on the industry and the
season so I have some examples here from
some tips that we gave to a health care
center for how it can use less energy in
the wintertime by using less heat and so
we want to target these companies or
target these businesses based on their
business type so that we can send them
tips and we can compare them to similar
businesses so the first project that I'm
going to talk about is the business type
prediction where the goal is to classify
the business as in the business type so
we have four hundred and ninety thousand
businesses from D&B
and those all have ground truth on their
business type but so and that's a very
small segment of the business population
and that's why this is an important
problem so on these unseen businesses
will we be able to predict the actual
business type there are ten business
types and all listed here and the way
that we approach this problem is we're
going to treat the business name as a
bag of words representation
where we take the business name and then
we actually break it down into a feature
vector where a 1 in the vector indicates
that that word is in the business name
so we have a high dimensional sparse
feature space and representing the word
names the idea here is that businesses
with similar words in their names are
going to be within the similar business
type we tried a lot of different
algorithms on this just to see which one
worked the best a lot of your main
players SVM logistic regression we
through naive Bayes in there cuz why not
and and it did pretty well so this is
the ROC curve for our logistic
regression you can see the area under
the curve is quite high even amongst all
the classes we do very very well with
religious organization organizations
with a 99 percent or point 99 you can
imagine that a lot of those religious
organizations are going to have like
Church in their name or synagogue or
something along those lines and those
are all going to be grouped properly and
then overall here is how our the
different classifiers did before this
project we really really wanted to limit
false the false positive rate we do not
want to be comparing a restaurant to an
office or something along those lines so
the metric that we really cared about
was this one versus all true positive
rate at the 1% false positive rate and
for this analysis the best one that we
had was this random forest here and with
70% this is good enough to continue on
and actually start using this and
production lysing it part of me
mm-hmm yes yes so we are doing the one
verse all so predicting how if we can
classify it versus all yeah any other
questions about this the micro versus
macro is a small distinction on the
accuracy metrics basically the micro I'm
going to say this on the micro is the is
evaluated over all or is evaluated per
class and then the macro is averaged
over all yes it depends it's if the
denominator changes whether it's like
the number of classes or if it's the
number of examples yeah we can talk
about that afterwards we could okay and
then the next the next big research
project that we did for the small medium
business insights was predicting their
open closed hours so this is really
important if we're going to be comparing
these businesses to each other we don't
want to compare a bar that closes at
11:00 to a bar that closes f-4 because
they're gonna have very different energy
usage when it makes sense for their use
cases so the goal is to predict their
open and close business hours we had a
data set of 26,000 businesses with that
both had a mi data and had ground truth
in it I think you just leaned on the
light back there
thank you and so yes we need a mi data
for this and we also need the open our
ground truth we got that from factual
we're using ami data here because we
actually need to know what their usage
is per hour that way we can figure out
when they're not in business so here we
have two business types one that is open
during the day one that's open during
the night it's pretty easy to tell that
they are open at that time and if we
could just eyeball all 26,000 of these
it would be relatively easy to say okay
this one open its open at that time this
one's open at that time or closes at
that time so we used a relatively
straightforward algorithm we started at
the
the time the minimum average usage for
that business in one day and then we
took a step forward in a step backward
until we reached a certain threshold so
in this example it's 25% it was the
threshold that we used and therefore we
had the predicted open and predicted
closed hours that you see there any
questions on that algorithm it's just a
simple walk so then here's two examples
of day and night businesses that we
predicted we have the x here of one we
predicted them and then we also have
this little waste usage here that's the
yellow usage either when they're ramping
up or ramping down this is a really
great area for us to go in and send this
company some tips saying hey you're
using a lot of energy ramping up for the
day or hey you're using a lot ramping
down here are some ways that you could
actually limit that and so here are the
results
we tried or we optimized the special
percentage using the xnor accuracy what
that means is we only said that it was a
correct classification if we predicted
closed and the actual business was
closed or open and the actual business
was open and we were able to get 75%
accuracy using a threshold of 40 percent
so that's 40 percent from your minimum
to your maximum usage and over here this
is the plot that we used to figure out
that threshold because at point four our
accuracy is the highest over our two
metrics and you can see performance is
relatively stable across the different
threshold values and then I didn't have
room on this slide but this algorithm
steadily beats the baseline models of
predicting always open or always closed
so this does very well 75 percent
accuracy means that we can go forth with
this project any questions about
small-medium business insights before
passage mark yeah
so the factual data is not available for
everyone so that's the problem so we
only have 26,000
actual open closed hours through factual
there's a lot more companies than that
and so we need to have a method like
this where we can fill in all the gaps
any other questions yes
why 75% well that's the dream right but
wheels
well no I'm saying we were able to get
75% that yes yes well if it was 25% then
we would not go forward with the project
are you are you asking like was there a
threshold that we needed to pass no that
was not yes yes yeah exactly so there
are a lot of issues when you start
getting into like there are challenges
when a business goes close during the
afternoon say then this simple algorithm
breaks down because we are only finding
the one part where they're closed we're
not looking for multiple closed times so
even though it is the 40% that's in the
minimum so for example this business
right here it looks like it's closed two
times a day
right maybe between like zero and three
and then also between 9 and 18 it looks
like it could be closed twice but we're
only predicting one open closed so our
accuracy is gonna be much lower for this
yeah
they could be more interesting to sort
of see I do have a confusion matrix and
I didn't put it in the slides card-index
probably raw yeah this if you don't have
to cook anything yeah okay
what was the name of that okay thank you
okay interesting okay I'll take it in
the back has you've been holding your
hand up for a long time yeah yeah we
promise we data scientists don't measure
it yeah it definitely works I mean but
at this point we've sent out a lot fewer
of these business communications than we
have for the regular home energy reports
so it is kind of a sample size issue
yes all right to mark there we go okay
thank you my name is Mark like zero I am
NOT a data scientist but I'm working
with the data science team I'm an
implementation engineer also like zero
so what my project has been focused on
electric vehicle detection so first off
why do we want to detect electric
vehicles
well electric vehicles take a lot of
energy and when people get home at night
and just plug their car and after work
they're putting a strain on the grid at
a time that's very bad for the grid to
be taking that strain because people are
coming home turning on lights turning on
radios TVs and whatnot so the utilities
are very interested in trying to deflect
that usage out too late to later hours
overnight in particular so here's though
so what they do is that they have
electric vehicle rates that people can
sign up for where let's see what you can
see there where people pay a slightly
higher rate during the day in order to
get a deeper discount at night when they
charge their car
so obviously utilities are very
interested in this data and finding out
where EVs are and so not only to
encourage those people individually to
sign up for electric vehicle rates we've
heard anywhere from a third only a third
to half of customers are actually signed
up for
evie rates that have v's from the
utilities but also to prepare sort of on
a more global scale for increased locked
vehicle adoption if there might be some
need for additional transmission in
certain areas if there's neighborhoods
where people are buying lots of TVs or
potentially to install charging stations
so so what can we do well the easiest
thing to do in the this sort of just a
proof-of-concept kind of what we'll call
the first pass attempt in our model is
to just look at customers we have
customer data for for one utility where
they have customers on electric vehicle
rates and we we have about 15,000
customers in that data set and then to
balance that data set off with non-tv
customers we just selected an equal
number of customers that are on the
standard rate for that utility and and
just to make it so that it's somewhat
coming from the same area we looked at
the number of V's per city and then
selected only from the top cities for
our non-tv customers and as I said we're
just going to for simplicity include
only the electric vehicle rate data
after they've signed up for the e V rate
so as you could expect we're gonna see
the effects of the pricing on the data
so let's just take a look at all evey
customers average hourly usage and
compare that to Nani V customers so
that's what we have here you can see
that the electric vehicle rate for this
utility kicks in at 11 o'clock and
there's a huge signal there as people
turn on their their cars to charge they
probably have timers so that car so that
the vehicle starts charging precisely at
11:00 and then over to over the night
more and more cars get fully charged and
the usage drops down but we see that
very clear signal that is very distinct
pattern from the average non TV user one
thing you might notice is that not only
is the shape very different for evey
customers there's also a huge magnitude
difference in the total usage and so
that was somewhat surprising so what I
looked at is just the distribution of
total daily usage based on four V's and
non V's one thing you'll see and this is
due to the electric vehicle itself is
that the peak is slightly shifted
forward for the evey customers but more
the reason that we're seeing this high
jump an average is that there's this
long tail and it keeps going on I didn't
cut off the graph just for clarity of
very very high users and that's just
because I like people that own electric
vehicles are rich and so they use a lot
of energy they have big houses and so
we're having a demographic shift in the
e V versus non TV customers that's
causing that that disconnect there and
but it's important to note that that
although you do have this long tail
there are a lot of kV customers that
have a total usage that is very
comparable to non TV customers so you
can't just use total you total daily
usage as a signal of somebody to
somebody that has an e V that would be
I'm blanking on the way to say that
correlation not a causation there we go
so so that's one thing that we can do we
can do a machine learning model and I'll
show you the results of that when we're
only using the electric vehicle data
after they've signed up for their
electric vehicle rate but that's kind of
cheating because we already know that
the price signals have shifted their
usage out to us very specific time of
day and we're gonna and we're gonna take
advantage of that our loom machine
learning model is gonna learn that and
then we're gonna be able to predict
people that have v's because they're
signed up for an e V rate so it would be
great if we had it sorry if we had a
third party data source that said these
people own TVs but are not on TV rates
we didn't have that readily at hand so
what we decided to do was to write that
would be great bring it on what we
decided to do is look at evey usage for
customers before they signed up for
their evey rate so the idea is that the
assumption there is that people switch
to their Eevee rate after they've
purchased their Eevee and so they've
started to charge their car but they're
not paying attention to the time of data
they're doing it because they have no
reason to that's obviously an imperfect
assumption a lot of people are know
exactly when they're going to get their
Eevee and then will sign up for their
Eevee rate to just perfectly coincide
with that and we'll always have that
behavior so we're going to have some
misidentified customers in that case but
it's what we can it's the best we can do
with the data that we have at the moment
so what time period should we use for
this sort of look look up window the
time prior to when people sign up for an
e V rate but are still hopefully still
hopefully have an e V so I'll kind of
step through forward in time for evey
customers as we get closer and closer to
their start date for the EB rate so if
we look further far enough back and it's
really not that far it's only just you
know a month before in that in the sort
of second month before they sign up we
can see a very similar load profile for
the EB customers as compared to the non
EB customers again with that shift
upward because of the total usage as we
move forward in time we can start to see
that their usage in the evening hours is
increasing and also overnight and that
we're starting to get this bump here and
of course even if people are instant not
incentivized to charge their car in the
very in the very early evening you know
at a very specific time they will still
have charted their car charging
overnight because it takes a while for a
car to charge and they come home and
they plug their car in so that's why
we're still seeing this signal here it's
just not quite as strong as we see it as
we move forward in time so now in the
turquoise here what you see is them just
in the two weeks prior to when they sign
up to their evey rate and we're starting
to see not only are they charging their
car at night but they're already
starting to adopt that behavior of
plugging their car in at 11 o'clock and
then once it gets to the point where
they're after they've signed up for the
IV rate that signals much clearer yeah
yes of course well more and more people
are we have certain people we don't know
that everybody you know as we move
forward closer and closer to that EB
rate that EB start date more and more of
those customers are on have electric
vehicles and so there the total usages
is changing yeah so to kind of strike
that balance between we think that the
customers have an e V at this point
versus they've already changed their
behavior in anticipation of the e V rate
we chose this kind of two week window
here between 15 and 30 days
prior to when they sign up and just as a
sort of further verification what I'm
showing here is just again that total
daily usage histogram and you can see
that the people that are that the
distribution after they've signed up and
the one in that 15 to 30 day windows has
a reasonably similar shape so they're
we're not getting we we have seen most
of those customers switch over to have
an Eevee is what that's telling us okay
so we use the logistic regression model
and we just looked at this average usage
by our the ones the data that I've been
showing you so far no additional
features at least to start and then when
we just looked at the sort of the sort
of baseline accuracy where we just have
a 50/50 percent threshold we see that
our what we call the first pass where
we're only using the data after their
Eevee start date we get very good
identification results almost you know
78% and then we certainly have a
decrease but we're still getting a
fairly decent match rate for the
customers when we only are using that
data prior to when they signed up and we
can dig down a little bit further and
look at our persistent recall curve and
our ROC curve again we're certainly
losing some precision as we as we have
the sound experiment as compared to that
first pass model but the if we start to
say we want to have for example say an
80% precision we can get you know and
close to a 60 percent recall for the
sound experiment so that's certainly
worth pursuing further and there's a
possibility that again you know some of
these customers that we're calling v's
for in the sound experiment actually
don't have an Eevee yet because they
don't sign up for the Eevee until they
actually have their car so that's that's
all I have
yes
I see what it does because much less
this is just very preliminary so we are
not we haven't even look at this have
this look at the rest of population
where that provides we are just giving
our we just wanted a very simple
experiment it's not that great there's
plenty more work when you do marketing
to start this project you can look at
time serious stuff he's just looking at
overall average hourly there's a whole
bunch of awesome we can do once we get
good enough on just this very simple
experiment that are looking at
anecdotally I've noticed that numbers
have solar PV I don't know I don't know
the tariff interaction about whether
they're eligible for this in particular
this particular population that we
haven't done any sort of cross analysis
to see if they do have PV s but we have
done that in the past and there is a
definite correlation between customers
that yeah it that is statistically
significant yeah
so for the bar graph I'm this is the oh
sorry that one no sorry the non-tv
customers have less usage that's the
total daily usage the peak is lower and
that's the more usage sorry yeah sound
experiment was just kind of the word we
use to just talk about the the data set
where we just took that data prior to
their electric vehicle start date the
electric vehicle rates start date and so
that was just kind of how we were
referring to the two
so are you taking this but then once you
get more data are using yes so during
what we found you is research so these
are some recent projects where we are
simplicity during the research phase one
just enjoyed the beginning once we're
ready to replace I'm ready
production-wise it goes into production
and he is basically retraining all of
our models on whatever cadence makes
sense of something that's monthly or
like something that's based on building
yes once a super-eruption we are
generally would be wanting these things
to take advantage of
I mean so it hasn't been just steam has
an interesting story so actually one of
Oracle's recent acquires what's data
raker they actually do the exact that
exact analysis to figure out who's got a
toddler who doesn't and they have a
bunch of security problems basically
from people they are uncomfortable that
your
like what they're in that crowd by the
way if you want to so generally if you
get solar you have to tell your utility
and you get on some sort of great solar
rate and we to our utility partners we
get all that information let's we get
great information for if you get all
sorts of stuff including use of energy
usage rate information and sometimes
demographics some other stuff so that
unlike the Eevee
where basically you may or may not be on
electric vehicle rate if you have
knowledge of vehicle I think for solar
is pretty much across the board you're
gonna have to deal with utility in some
way and so they know that information
and they pass that along right
right
yeah so basically if you have solar your
utility generally knows about it